Alors, je suis en bonne santé
Ne vous inquiétez pas, d'ailleurs, j'me plains pas avec mon corps, c'est juste que
le mec qui a imaginé mon corps avait perdu les plans ! Il est parti en impro !
(accent allemand) Je m'appelle Hanz, und je suis le créateur du corps de Cyprien
Pour faire simple, j'ai fait n'importe quoi !
En terme de pilosité faciale par exemple.
Mes poils ne savent pas où s’arrêter, ma barbe monte jusqu'en haut des joues.
Bientôt sous mes yeux!
Qui a décidé de ça?
(accent allemand) Ah? Ja! Comment va ta famille? Je travaille sur un nouveau modèle...
(accent allemand) ...beaucoup de travail en ce moment.
(accent allemand) Ja! Ja! Sehr gut! Embrasse ta famille pour moi! Ja, auf wiedersehen!
As.. Wow!
Bon, ça fait pas très viril à avouer, voilà, je m'épile!
Parce que sinon, ça fait dégueulasse, je n'ai pas le choix.
Mais le pire, ce sont mes sourcils, en fait, hein, parce que parfois
dans les sketchs, je déconne, je me fais un mono-sourcil, mais en vrai, c'est ce qu'il m'arrive si je ne m'épile pas.
À croire que mes sourcils sont fait pour se réunir...
(musique : Vangelis - Chariots of Fire)
On va rester dans le poil,
mes cheveux ont une implantation particulière.
Je les coiffe, mais le matin au réveil ou quand je sors de la douche,
ils reprennent leur forme originèle, c'est à dire
applatis dessus, relevés sur les côtés
(endormi) Oh! Putain...
Attends, mais tu ressembles à...
- à Wolverine !
Au chanteur -M- !
(imitant en chantant) Qui de nous deux?
ça t'amuse... Hein? Connard!
Bon, j'ai des problèmes de vue
hein, ça ça ... tout le monde est au courant, mais bien sûr, je ne pouvais pas faire comme tout le monde... Non !
Œil droit: Myopie. Oeil gauche: Astigmate et hypermétrope
Un nouveau délire...
D'ailleurs, on voit bien la différence entre mes deux verres.
Pourkeuwa?
(accent allemand) Ach... Nein. Nein. J'ai tout mélangé. Bon, on va prendre ces deux là.
Ils ont l'air de la même couleur.
J'ai un problème de sudation.
Quand quelqu'un dit: "J'ai un problème de sudation." ça veut dire qu'il transpire comme un gros porc.
Je suis obligé d'utiliser un "déo" spécial trouvable en pharmacie.
car depuis que je suis ado, je transpire des litres... Surtout des aisselles.
Même s'il fait moyen chaud, même s'il fait tiède, même s'il fait froid
À peine que je sors dehors quelques secondes, j'ai des auréoles... Sympa !
Encore une bonne journée qui commence !
Bon, j'ai un petit peu abusé avec mon corps aussi,
il faut savoir que quand je suis arrivé sur Paris à 18 ans, j'ai pris 5 kilos en quelques semaines.
Puis j'ai pris 5 kilos en plus depuis... Pour être, heu... C'est plus correct
C'est parce que j’étais stressé en fait, et mon métabolisme a réagi...
Ah non ? Ah non ! En fait , c'est parce que je mangeais comme un gros porc, c'est vrai...
(musique : The Turtles - Happy Together)
Et c'est là que mon corps intervient puisqu'il a décidé de ne pas grossir comme tout le monde !
(accent allemand) Bon, je ne vais pas vous mentir. Là, on a foiré.
Je pourrais avoir: du ventre, des joues... Mais non, quand je grossis
le haut du corps ne bouge pas, je prends uniquement, des fesses, des cuisses, et des poignées d'amour.
Oui ! Exactement comme une femme !
Ah voilà ! Ah , on a bien bossé, ah ouais , on a mis toute la graisse dans les cuisses, les poignées d'amour... Ah ça va être une très belle femme !
Ah ouais, elle va être super jolie avec des jolies courbes et des... C'est un... C'est un homme ?
Depuis , depuis le début, c'est un homme ?
Beh ouais, mais, vous nous dîtes ça maintenant, ça fait 26 ans c'est une femme, on met de la graisse dans ses cuisses... Putain !
Et ouais... Mais euh... Et bah communiquez !
Je suis comme ça, j'ai des grosses hanches, j'ai des grosses cuisses.
Vous voyez les mannequins avec des hanches large de comme ça ?
Beh, on pourrait en rentrer un dans chaque jambe... Voilà, c'est la vie.
Il y'a beaucoup d'homme qui ont peur dans la rue de matter un cul et de s'apercevoir qu'en fait c'est un autre homme.
Moi, ma peur en plus de ça, c'est que le mec a qui on matte le cul, ce soit moi !
Voilà ma vie !
Et puis, j'ai décidé de me reprendre en main pour perdre mes kilos en trop
surtout après cet été après avoir vu une photo de moi
Oui... Ce sont bien des seins que vous voyez là.
Désolé, c'est ma faute ! Parce qu'il y'avait de la graisse en plus, j'en ai mis en haut !
Je me suis donc mis au régime
Hop hop hop! Je suis désolé hein, la vidéo sur le régime, c'est moi, c'est déjà fait, j'ai perdu 26 kilos
et elle a cartonné...
- Et, tu en as repris combien depuis?
Allez, je te laisse, salut, hein ! Bye !
Mon régime est plutôt simple, je ne mange plus de pain et je mange léger le soir. C'est tout !
Et contrairement à ce que pourrait penser, un régime, ce n'est pas si compliqué
Jour 1:
Hmm, elle est bonne cette soupe en fait...
Jour 7:
(pleure) Ma vie, c'est de la merde !
(en colère) Déjà que de base, j'ai faim tout le temps, alors là, je ne pense qu'à ça !
Je veux du gras !
Si tu en veux, prends en !
Ah merci beaucoup...
Merci.
Je prends aussi un peu de...
Wooooah ! Merci man !
Mais la grande révolution dans ma vie, c'est que je fais du sport
C'est vraiment tout nouveau pour moi parce que je n'ai jamais été sportif.
J'ai toujours été le dernier choisi dans les équipes en sport à l'école
Je... J'hésite... J'hésite... On va prendre hmm
JE SUIS LE DERNIER ! Tu n'as pas le choix !
On va faire un "plouf plouf"... hein?
En tant que "non sportif", je l'avoue, c'est dur pour moi de courir
J'en ai parlé avec des gens qui font du "running" régulièrement, ils m'ont tous sorti sans aucune exception :
La course, clairement, c'est comme une drogue.
(ricane) Il a raison, la course, c'est exactement comme une drogue
Hein? On est d'accord?
On est d'accord ! On est d'accord ! La course, c'est comme une drogue, c'est tout pareil.
Excusez moi, je vous entends parler, parce que, la course, c'est comme une drogue.
LA COURSE
C'EST COMME
UNE
DROGUE !
C'est comme une drogue.
Excusez moi, j'habite en dessous en faite, je vous entends parler et de dire que la course, c'est comme une drogue.
C'est comme une drogue, la course, tu m'entends?!
Alors, c'est marrant parce que, je ne savais pas que la drogue, ça faisait ça...
Oh putain les crampes !
Oh les crampes ! Putain ! Ça nique ! Ah j'arrête ! J'arrête la drogue !
Bref, j'ai perdu 7 kilos en 1 mois et demi donc j'y crois...
Je vous referai une vidéo dans quelques mois pour savoir où on en est, si je n'ai pas repris.
En tout cas, assumez vous dans votre corps, qu'il soit, pileux, non pileux, de toutes les formes, de toutes les couleurs
transpirant ou non, comme vous voulez. Assumez vous, c'est important. Voilà, c'est tout pour mon corps.
Ach ! Nein ! Je n'ai pas terminé encore, encore une petite surprise, il va commencer a perdre ses cheveux !
Quoi ?! Mais non !